[Music]
every one of us has
something that makes us special welcome
to the jungle thanks for subscribing
a part of who we are that simply can't
be ignored
i'm standing here with uh big dick stacy
talk to me about the team's expectations
as we go into this tournament we're
pretty thick and pumped right now
um we're going in just heads up going
straight in there
nice and hard and i'll see what we got
and deliver that one
unique trait that is unmistakably us
i believe it was youtube it was not me
i believe it was you little man i think
you want it
and you like it how much am i getting
paid to be here again
eight inches oh [ __ ] goddammit
and for most streamers and esports
personalities these signature traits are
cultivated by giving fans a window into
their lives
he's not even in this native is youtube
[ __ ] maybe i completely forgot it was
i'm so sorry i'm so sorry
no no i didn't i didn't realize how long
i was being it's just a headphone
but what if i told you that there was a
content creator who
quite literally earned the adoration of
millions of people
without ever really letting them know
who he was
well for corp's husband the mysterious
owner of maybe the internet's most
iconic voice that's exactly what
happened
oh my hi corpse why does corpse sound
like vin diesel
bro corp sounds like five vin diesels
all collided
into one person his voice is nuts like
how far do your balls have to drop to
have that
so how did a faceless content creator
become one of the most
recognizable stars on youtube and in
what sense is his greatest
blessing also his greatest curse
i was sitting there with like an eye
patch on my whole arm is numb like i'm
bleeding out the nose and i'm just
playing video games like oh i can't
it shouldn't be i don't think that's
something i can like do for a long time
so not a lot is known about corp's
husband save the things he chooses to
share with his followers
there is not a single picture of me from
before youtube with my entire
face in it there is of course the voice
it's lovely to see you again oh my god
his voice
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] but outside of what
corpse
sounds like he's basically one of the
internet's greatest mysteries
because he's never actually shown his
face which might explain why pictures of
his hands
torso or even hair send his fan base
into a frenzy i love that strand of hair
as a thing
it's so great i've never seen anything
like that before
what we do know is that corpse is an
aspiring musician
a creepy ass copy pasta narrator
i open my main door and see not my
grandmother but
a man oh my
his sense of humor is about as dark as
his name suggests
your first full body appearance in front
of millions of people
what do you wear puffy straight jackie
and supposedly he kind of looks like lil
xan
people joke that i look like him
sometimes even though i don't think we
do
i got stopped outside of his store the
other day but like five people that ran
up on me and then they [ __ ] dabbed me
up and went lil saying little xan
i'm not lil zay but one thing is for
sure
people love to speculate do you have
boobs i mean technically
probably i don't know i don't know i
have uh two areolas just like you
maybe unless you have like no nipples or
something i don't know what boobs
entails though
anyway corpse kicked off his youtube
venture in july of 2015
after someone pointed out that his voice
would be perfect for narrating
horror stories and for the next few
years
that's exactly what he did cell 9 held a
young woman with
fiery eyes she had a tight muzzle
strapped around her face
muffling her screams her eyes pierced
straight through me with
terror tammy had to practically drag her
from her cell
oh come on renee he's not going to hurt
you
corpse's channel was on a slow but
steady upward trajectory but his viewers
noticed he sporadically took breaks from
uploading new videos
like in 2018 when he didn't upload for
10
long months corpse later revealed that
during that time
not only was he dealing with his own
mounting health concerns
but that he'd received some devastating
news
i found out my mom had cancer and we
don't really talk much
so she had had it for a bit and
[Music]
um yeah so i'm in a double arm brace in
my bed not talking to anybody not able
to move and i just
find that out and it really like set me
off
i didn't i didn't know what to do but
this wasn't the first time that corpse
had found himself
suffering from strange debilitating
symptoms
you see ever since he was young corpse
had dealt with some
pretty severe anxiety that would often
leave him shaking and keep him inside
for days at a time
corpse eventually dropped out of middle
school but because of the no child left
behind act
he was forced to attend high school
where he
slept through most of his classes and
didn't get along with his teachers
yeah i got kicked out of every high
school
and i never went back to school and the
thing about anxiety is that
not only can it wreak some serious havoc
on your life
but its symptoms can mimic a ton of
other illnesses
making it very difficult to diagnose
what is actually causing the health
problems in question
and for years corpse had been trying to
figure out exactly what those causes
were
but in 2018 when he began to experience
electrical shock sensations in his brain
numbness in his arms and trouble with
his eyesight
corpse figured that anxiety simply
couldn't be the only culprit
and those suspicions were only confirmed
when he was officially diagnosed with
fibromyalgia
have you ever broken like an arm or a
leg or something and you've been in a
cast not able to do so that's kind of
what it feels like just it suffered
perpetually
now getting hit with a diagnosis like
that is bad enough on its own
but on top of that corpse also found out
that he was suffering from a number of
other illnesses such as acid reflux
disease which
if left untreated can actually lead to
esophageal cancer
i had a camera stuck down my throat the
other day by the other day i mean like
two years ago i
can literally post my vocal chords on
instagram as well it probably looks like
gore or some [ __ ] though
now i know everything i've told you so
far sounds pretty awful so
you might be wondering where the
blessing part of this whole thing comes
in
well in corpse's case because of his
illness
his already deep voice took on that
instantly recognizable
i just gargled some whiskey with gravel
quality that was about to turn him into
an
overnight internet sensation there's
nowhere to measure that
like my illness does affect my larynx
yes but i've always had a deep voice i
think the rasp
partially comes right but what corpse
didn't anticipate was that his
voice would turn out to be a siren song
for subscribers
and that really became clear in
september of 2020 when he joined
pewdiepie and a few
other big name streamers for a friendly
game of among us
no corpse what's going on hello friends
wow
wait what corpse's voice is like
infrasonic is that real
no oh my god it's real believe me
it can't be corpse four times in a row
right
just two weeks after that fateful
collaboration
corpse's youtube channel had skyrocketed
from 1 million subs
to 3 million subs with everyone
clamoring to know more about him
and no one was immune to his allure men
women politicians k-pop stars
it didn't matter yeah it's corpse yeah
corpse that's really really low price
it's so cool though you sound sick
oh oh you haven't met corpse of corpse
i want to hear what aoc has to say
i was by the office
[Music]
i don't know corpse but god damn i'm a
fan i'm already a fan i gotta say
as corpse's sub count continued to
skyrocket
so did his fans obsession with him
someone tattooed my name on them today i
thought that was
cool corpse's music even found its way
into the spotlight to the point where he
was trending on spotify
netting him another two million subs on
his secondary channel
i feel like i'm about to throw up i'm
joining i can have
logic join the game and he's reciting my
lyrics to me
the last thing i expected from one of
the first rappers i was really into is
logic and then he joins and just
immediately starts reciting my lyrics
like what do you do
what are you even doing that situation
but the sudden explosion in popularity
also meant that people became more
intent than ever on
trying to find out everything they
possibly could about corpse
especially what he looked like a lot of
people think it's like a business thing
or a gimmick i just
deeply hate my face and people's
expectations at this point
are ridiculous and unachievable meeting
the hopes of more than
7 million rabid fans is enough to make
anyone
question whether they can handle that
kind of attention and corpse was no
different
the pressure began to adversely affect
his mental health
i hate you and i think you should die
you are an idiot and i hate your voice
there's no room on this paper to
properly describe how much i hate you go
die just every single day i read
like stuff about me that's blatantly
untrue and like
all these reasons for people to dislike
me or whatever
it's not a big deal but like it's really
stressful
and so i have the opportunity to leave
everything
and that's not something that a lot of
people have and i've been
really really like considering it lately
if corpse's latest revelations are
anything to go by he might just vanish
from the public eye
as suddenly as he had first appeared
kind of like one of his beloved horror
stories our innate drive to avoid
uncertainty and solve mysteries
might ironically lead to this particular
one
remaining unsolved forever if corpse
does end up pulling the plug on his
social media stardom before we know who
he is
it would be very much in line with what
he always said made him
stick with it until now screwing with
people
i'm always looking to do something big
and just
with everyone so whenever i'm not like
doing that i kind of feel
unfulfilled and everyone that ever had
the pleasure of hearing him speak
might be left wondering was he ever
really there is that your real voice
no it's all the [ __ ] it's all a
facade it's all about voice changer
none of it is real this is all a dream
[Music]
who the [ __ ] is this lil son
this is some hardcore zoomer [ __ ] dude i
don't know how to
say that or what the [ __ ] a little zen
is going to
look up a pronunciation video for this
whatever this thing is
youtube ads they make us and they break
us
little zan corpse's youtube channel
skyrocketed
from 1 million subs to 3 million subs
had skyrocketed just be perfect no pun
intended
grammar nerd